welcome to the pink marketing show the
podcast for growing and scaling your
business with online video
I'm Heather Torres and I'm Sean Connell
and we are so fired up you're here
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or
maximize online video across social
media this is for you and on today's
episode we're going to talk about the
vision the heart and what to expect from
the think marketing show but first who
are we and I'm fired up Heather to be
here this is the foundational episode
and yeah let's talk about first who we
are and why we're even doing this
podcast yeah so Sean Sean can tell you
are a college dropout small town kid
started making videos in your bedroom
and a decade later now you've built a
multiple seven-figure or multi-million
dollar business media company with over
a hundred million video views
congratulations a 1.5 million
subscribers on YouTube not even that
you've also done multiple six figures in
the event space multiple six figures in
speaking and coaching multiple six
figures in brand deals working with
brands like Canon and Amazon and Sony
and also 7 figures in affiliate
marketing and 7 figures in digital
products can we clap it up great job I
mean that was that was a lot of flexing
there but I guess reason we kind of
wanted to share that was because that's
the heart behind this podcast is having
been in this for a decade having been
making so many mistakes and also have
having had a lot of successes and so
that's we want to share is all of these
tips that we've learned in the trenches
building this stuff but then of course
I'm here with Heather Taurus the host of
the think marketing show and for people
that are just meeting you you're a multi
passionate entrepreneur you've done all
kinds of things you've done social media
for like Washington state parks you've
done fitness studios and
brick-and-mortar businesses and you've
helped scale businesses with marketing
and paid advertising and you're also the
chief operation officer
think media you've helped build the team
here a leader teamwork and operations
and those are some of the topics right
that's the essence of think marketing is
the behind-the-scenes stuff for building
your business
you're also a content creator on YouTube
helping moms with your own YouTube
channel one of the content creators on
think media which is our main tech
channel and you're doing a lot of other
cool things one of your biggest passions
is productivity and time management
which is something we all need as
entrepreneurs because it's hard to stay
on top of all of this marketing stuff
plus the business building stuff plus
life plus business and so you've got all
kinds of strategies to help
purpose-driven entrepreneurs maximize
their time so they can get more done
yeah that did sound like a lot of
flexing but I'm proud of it I think we
have a lot to give and you know part of
the reason we wanted to do this like you
said was because over the decade that
you've been working and I've been
working in this space we have done a lot
of things wrong and we've had a lot of
struggles but we've done things right
and we want to help you shorten that
learning curve so that's part of the
reason why we wanted to make this show
yeah and there's something about trying
to find simplicity some of the topics
we'll dive into our complex in nature
but we want to simplify marketing in
general because marketing isn't even the
main focus of so many business owners
but it's something you have to do we say
you got a date Sam who Sam we're
actually both by the way married two
different people other people and it
just has a foundational thing people see
some videos together and whatnot I'm
married to my wife Sonya Kanno and you
I'm married to my wonderful husband
Isaiah Torres and both of us though
think we both need to still date Sam and
what Sam sales and marketing like if you
want to keep your business going
you gotta master sales you got a master
marketing but those topics can be kind
of complex so we want to simplify those
and then also we unify here on this
podcast around some of our core values I
mean for us that's faith that's family
that's legacy and you know Heather
marketing kind of has a bad rap and
there's different flavors of marketing
out there marketing is even one of those
topics that can rub people the wrong way
because it's maybe known for being shady
or being
forceful and we really believe though
that marketing is so important and that
marketing changes lives when done right
and that we can ultimately build high
impact and high profit businesses that
not just impact people but can change
the world through marketing yeah and for
us it really is about building
relationships building relationships
with people who are wanting the same
things that we are building right
building those lifestyle type businesses
and helping people understand that you
can have an online in an offline
business but using the power of online
video is really the vehicle absolutely
and of course you know what topics can
you expect from this show well as the
author of YouTube secrets and as maybe
if you're new too if you've already
known me for a while YouTube is
certainly a major theme and that's gonna
be a major theme of the show video
marketing in general I mean we're so
passionate about video marketing on
LinkedIn on Instagram what's happening
on tik-tok in emerging platforms on
Facebook on Twitter and then of course
paid video advertising but there's so
much that goes on behind the business
like what's the point of this think
marketing show because we have think
media I've got my channel that I do with
Bengie call video influencers but we
realized that where are we talking about
like email marketing where are we
talking about like the blocks where we
build websites and you build pages and
what are some of the other topics
Heather yeah I'm really excited to go
deeper into creating and selling digital
courses you know digital courses is what
allowed Shawn your family and my family
to really have freedom and we want to
share how you do it here on think
marketing also things like advanced
strategies for using YouTube so that you
can build your business and your brand
on your own terms it's so important to
us that you see you know that ice
breaker or the iceberg
it's what's below the water that we want
to share here on the think marketing
show yeah we'll be talking about
software tools and just all of those
kinds of elements so that you can
actually build a real business on the
other side of your social media and your
video marketing efforts so where can you
find us well wherever you're listening
to this right now you can of course
scribe right here but the think
marketing show is gonna be on Apple
podcast it's gonna be on YouTube it's
gonna be on Spotify SoundCloud wherever
you consume your audio or your video
content we're gonna be there so make
sure to hit that subscribe button so you
don't miss an episode
yeah and if you are on Apple right now
we'd love for you to leave a review and
let us know what you think of this first
episode and let us know what type of
topics you'd like us to cover and you
can also reach us on Instagram
that's right and so if you actually want
to get involved a couple things number
one make sure you subscribe so that way
you start getting these episodes as
they're released and number two send us
a message you can tag us on Instagram
stories or DMS at Sean kennel Sean
kennel rhymes with channel first names
Sean s EAN last name kennel C a and and
e ll there's no way just an audio that
she would have been able to figure that
out so I'm sorry to have hit you with
that but it's essential so tag me on
Instagram or Heather Taurus which is
that Miss M RS miss Heather as Heather
would be spelled HEA H EA th er t o RR
es sorry to have burdened you with that
but we want to connect on Instagram so
DM us tag us on stories so we can hear
that you're listening to the podcast
that you're connecting and then when
you're subscribed and the cool thing is
is that the first episode is already out
on all these platforms so what can they
do next well I'd say go watch that
episode over on YouTube or go to the
next episode here in your podcasts app
yeah man we are fired up thank you so
much for being here at the Genesis the
ground floor the inception the very
bedrock of the think marketing show we
are fired up and we think that you're
gonna get so much value out of this
content that's truly gonna help you get
results and go further faster and
building your business with online video
online marketing and social media yes
and I'm excited because we did what you
say Shawn we punched fear in the face
and we pressed record so we certainly
did especially with those name
Spelling's this is this
just going for it and hitting record so
hey we'll see you in the next episode
and thanks so much for listening
[Music]